you're leaving work okay okay
and things got compromised out in the
world you were at work you're doing a
podcast episode or something and like
things just kind of hit that level where
it's like maybe a couple police
precincts have been taken over just by
vandals and crazies like like the
pendulum's starting to things are
getting like a wall right and then
everything The Purge right so you're
driving home you're getting [ __ ] Pam
Haynes is sending you have [ __ ] a
thousand hammers you know what I'm
saying like you're getting all of you
everybody's just texting you you know
Jocko's like I'm I'm not even waking up
tomorrow for work I'll be up off you
know I'm just gonna be up at 4 30 right
like everything's all what do you do
like how do you this is the end this is
when it's like all right Joe Rogan you
hear you know what I'm saying you hear
it just comes from God or from something
like a strong wind with a [ __ ] with a
voice box in it you it's like this is it
this is the apocalypse you're leaving
work this is it I guess you have to
respond to each individual situation
um on uh you it's like each thing will
be unique like is someone trying to
break in your house is someone trying to
rob your you know someone trying to
break in your car while you're driving
okay so you have an hour you have kind
of an hour right we'll give you 90
minutes you have 90 minutes to kind of
get before that you're gonna start to
feel some pressure
what do you do
I guess load up some magazine oh I'm
[ __ ] but I'm wondering what do you do
you know that's what I would do I'd
probably load up some magazines okay
into what
into guns okay okay okay yeah I see I
don't know if I can no at the
periodicals
like Sports Illustrated
I mean like an AR this guy's taking
information
I'm reading Time Magazine
yeah dude I'm like I just see Joe with
his many copies of Field and Stream as
you can [ __ ] live well you could use
those magazines as like protection you
stack enough of them okay so each other
okay now you're thinking slow bullets
down okay but say like you pick up your
family or something do you guys stay do
you have a bunker
I don't currently but this conversation
is making me want to Bunker yeah yeah
I've wanted a ranch for that very reason
like if [ __ ] goes completely sideways it
would be great if there's a place with
water and food where you got you got
your water you got your food like on the
property okay what about if you're kind
of in a city or you're in like a um like
what's maybe a business or something
you'd hold up in you'd think is viable a
business that I'd hold up in it would
have to be some sort of fortified
establishment like the mall no
no you'd have to get something that
you could defend dude the mall
yeah the mall I think you'd have
probably like think of all you could
hide in the [ __ ] Macy's behind all
the hiding Cinnabon behind the counter
yeah yeah
squeezing Frost into your mouth
it would be a good excuse to eat that
food because like look I gotta eat
something and that stuff will keep
because a lot of that stuff has like all
the um preservatives preservatives in it
so you'd have that you'd have mannequins
in there think about that you could set
up like a um like a mirage right right
right like a fake sort of situation yeah
where people would think that but you're
behind that yeah yeah so the mall I
think could be good hmm
yeah I've been thinking about that
um I would go to the mall really yeah
the mall yeah because nobody's at the
mall anymore but the dumbest people are
at the mall they're gonna [ __ ] it up for
you
they gotta go They're gonna go to the
Russians are here guys okay shut the
[ __ ] up I'm pretending to be a mannequin
I'm like hey
should be a medium
yeah that's gonna be the problem is dumb
people when [ __ ] goes south there's some
people that just like they're [ __ ]
they're ditch diggers they're dumb
people they're they're [ __ ] their
minimum wage thinkers but they're going
to have a lot of weapons though probably
maybe
I don't know every I think a lot of
people have weapons now but I think if
things go sideways
well a lot of people are gonna panic in
the chaos right oh immediately people
will be panicking people be trying to
group up some people will be trying to
salvage [ __ ] that right is gonna go that
person's gonna go yeah there's gonna be
a lot of people that are going to fall
apart
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one